según la agencia de meteorología de
australia se trata de inundaciones no
vistas en el país desde 1961 hace 60
años se concentran principalmente en el
estado de nueva gales del sur cuya
capital es sídney pero también están en
alerta a otros estados de la costa este
australiana como lo son queensland y
también este el estado de victoria cuya
capital es melbourne es decir que 10 de
los 25 millones de habitantes que tenía
australia están bajo el riesgo de esta
tormenta la magnitud de esta tormenta
según lo han dicho los expertos es
equivalente al tamaño de alaska o de 300
millones de canchas de fútbol los
organismos de emergencia han hecho más
de 700 rescates se han recibido ocho mil
llamadas de auxilio y las inundaciones
han afectado carreteras viviendas y
también cultivos mientras miles de
personas siguen siendo evacuadas y
tratan de salvar sus pertenencias el
gobierno federal ha anunciado ayudas
económicas para los afectados lo
preocupante es que las lluvias van a
seguir por los próximos tres días y solo
hacia el miércoles o jueves empezarán a